l'art c'est délicat et ça demande pas
mal de choses pour soit bien fait une
intention de la technique faut que votre
oeuvre soit faite au bon moment et
parfois ça se passe pas comme prévu ça
va et bah on peut partir de cet imprévu
pour faire autre chose une autre oeuvre
et laisser la première idée de l'artiste
inachevé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première forme d'inachevé à laquelle
on peut penser c'est celle qui fait écho
à l'inrs abouti comme l'homme qui se
trouve derrière moi ah oui là comme ça
ce transit à l'art abouti et pour mieux
comprendre il faut connaître son
histoire en transit dans leur funéraire
c'est une sculpture représentant à mort
celui ci n'est pas n'importe lequel
puisqu'il s'agit d'un transit réalisé
par girolamo della robbia suite à une
commande de catherine de médicis
la sculpture fut commencée en 1565 mais
l'oeuvre resté inachevé suite à une
décision de la reine
l'oeuvre était selon elle trop réaliste
se transigent donc dû finir sur son
tombeau l'inachèvement prendront qui s'y
trouvent sur le commanditaire mais peut
très bien prendre aux sources chez
l'artiste lui-même
c'est quelque chose qui arrive assez
souvent et l'une des raisons pour être
directement liées à l'argent en 1802 le
louvre demanda à jean auguste dominique
ingres de copier ce tableau de poussin
un graphique la somme de 960 francs et
alors qu'il commence et réalise qu'il
voudrait augmenter la somme est négocié
sans succès et finalement ne termine
jamais sa copie vous jouez le néron mais
si cet empereur romain qui a fait
assassiner sa mère et qu'il peut être
trop sable du grand patron d'hydro vous
en souvenez important les romains
avaient tout fait pour qu'on oublie et
c'est pour ça que le sénat avait voté sa
damnatio memoriae littéralement la
damnation de la mémoire
cela consiste en l'annulation des
honneurs l'effacement du nom sur les
monuments publics ou encore le
renversement des statue à son effigie
souza que la tête que vous voyez ici
bien qu'il ait lundi scapulaire de néron
c'est à dire la coiffure n'a pas son
visage
il s'agit du visage de titus un autre
empereur romain en fait pragmatique pour
réaliser la tête de titus les romains
auraient employé celui de néron mais
inachevé ne s'impose pas forcément ça
peut être un choix une esthétique et
dans ce domaine mais quel ange est
incontournable d'abord inachevée car
elle n'a pas toujours fini ses oeuvres
c'est le cas de l'un de ces esclaves
pour le tombeau du pape jules ii qu'on
voit ici mais il y avait aussi une
esthétique de l'image fric et cultivée
par michel-ange chez lui il y a deux
types d'inachevé on a pu penser que ces
oeuvres avaient cette esthétique car ils
en produisent et trop et qu'il voulait
vite passer à autre chose mais il n'en
est rien certaines oeuvres sont
délibérément inachevé afin d'avoir une
sorte de contraste de matières entre
celles traitées simplement à la pointe
et aux forêts et la partie très lisse et
très travaillée comme sur l'un des deux
esclaves sur cette oeuvre
on peut voir que les parties à achever
son saoul et partie achevé alors qu'en
sculpture en fonctionne par retrait de
matière et donc ça devrait être
l'inversé
donc c'est bien quelque chose qui vous
l'inachevé peut donc être un choix de
l'artiste comme pour solliciter
l'imagination du spectateur
mais si on allait plus loin que les
achever le concept même de l'inachevé
propos sur le permanent nous avons vu
des oeuvres qui ne bouge pas mais il
faut se rappeler que ce n'est pas le cas
de tout
au louvre certaines oeuvres sont siens
permanente qu'elles ne peuvent être
achevés d'inachevé fait partie de leur
essence c'est le cas de celle ci le
jardin des tuileries le jardin des
tuileries c'est un jardin à la française
c'est à dire qu'il est très carré très
ordonnée même si on y trouve quelques
bizarreries parfois par exemple certains
arbres sont vieux et ne sont pas taillé
à blanc rideau comme les autres et
ressorte donc au milieu d'un tout qui
lui est plutôt rigide
la grande difficulté de faire de l'art
avec du vivant et à la manière des
poupées russes
il ya dans cette oeuvre géante qu'est le
jardin des tuileries des multitudes
d'autres oeuvres en voici une
l'exode en 1658 élus la crue la plus
importante jamais enregistrée et il faut
refaire le jardin des tuileries
on demande naturellement à andré le
nôtre et on a fait quelque chose de
magnifique avec une atmosphère
différente dans chaque bosquet puis
vient la révolution un siècle plus tard
le jardin des tuileries devient le
jardin national et robespierre décide de
tout réaménager le style à la mode à
l'époque c'est celui de l'antiquité et
de tous les énormes projets qui appuient
y avoir c'est celui là qui reste alors
il faut imaginer qu'il n'y avait pas
d'eau auparavant et l'idée de
robespierre était de faire un endroit où
les sages vieillard
et donner des conseils aux jeunes
générations une dernière oeuvre qui
changent en permanence et bien
évidemment le louvre lui même le plus
grand musée du monde et même si sa
taille imposante lui donne cet aspect
immuable le musée en lui-même a beaucoup
évolué il suffit de regarder la fameuse
pyramide du louvre c'est 673 panneaux de
verre qui date de 1988 mais il ya aussi
ce qui n'existe plus comme le palais des
tuileries dont la construction fut
lancée par catherine de médicis en 1564
vous imaginez un immense palais qu'elle
est du pavillon de flore au pavillon de
marsan il a ensuite subi un incendie
volontaire en 1871
un incendie qui durera trois jours le
louvre n'avait donc pas du tout ce
visage là et je ne saurais vous dire
quel visage il aura demain et c'est les
choses inaboutie par contrainte ou par
volonté détruire pour mieux créer ou
encore embrassé l'impermanence pour
faire de l'art quelque chose qui ne se
terminent jamais inachevé n'a jamais été
à fuir ou à racheter au contraire il est
dans l'essence même de la noue peut s'en
rendre compte
ici au louvre cette vidéo aurait été
inachevé si je ne vous avais pas dit
qu'elle faisait partie d'un ensemble de
deux vidéos
nous avons parlé de l'inachevé nous
invite maintenant à parler de la femme
et si jamais vous avez déjà vu les deux
vidéos alors il me reste qu'à espérer
que ce voyage vous et plus il a remercié
le louvre et ses conservateurs qui ont
su me raconter leur plus belle histoire
et dont je n'ai été que le modeste
porte-parole n'hésitez pas à partager la
vidéo si vous a plu à les voir la chaîne
du louvre il ya notamment d'autres
collaborations et des youtuber qui ne
saurait tarder
ça va vous je crois je n'ai pas fini